should they make him chief meme officer
like if i'm twitter i just lean right
into it right cause you can basically go
[ __ ] what's he gonna do and you could
just be freaking out and all day every
day you literally are sitting by your
desk and you almost have to have like an
elon man if you're the ceo of twitter
right now and elon musk owns 9.2 percent
of your business he's your largest
outside shareholder you literally have
to have somebody your job is watch every
single tweet if he does anything tell me
like that's your only job is be the elon
guy yeah right somehow become friends
with him buy him lunch like do something
so that we have a good relationship here
and you're the elon guy
this that i don't think
actually matters when it comes to elon
what i think is better is literally just
make him chief medium officer be like we
are now going to add elon musk who is
our largest outside shareholders the
chief meme officer he'll go wild he'd
love it
people at twitter would be like this is
hilarious
and it would completely defuse the
situation and everyone would be like all
right like
how do you get mad at the chief meme
officer of course but i i don't know i
just find it hard to believe that he
doesn't already have a plan in place of
some capacity right maybe it's not
detailed maybe he doesn't know exactly
what he's going to do but again i find
it hard to believe that he just went and
bought three billion dollars worth of
stock now he's the largest outside
shareholder largest shareholder of
twitter bigger than blackrock bigger
than any individual right and uh just
given his personality part of me wants
to think that like he has a plan in
place again he's done irrational things
in the past and maybe he just kind of
did it on a whim but ultimately i find
it hard to believe like that's all he
wants can he get to demanding a board
seat with so much uh equity right he's
just like i'm sure yeah i own almost
like but he didn't have time for that
stuff right and i think he wants to be
ceo of twitter yeah i don't think he
wants to be the ceo either i don't think
he even wants to be on the board most
likely i don't think he bought three
billion dollars worth of stock to make
25 percent of it and pump the stock up
and then go sell it yeah you know what i
mean like i think there is something
how mad would people be if he was like
all right i just wanted to hold it i'm
day trading it like and he just saw he
tweeted just sold test or twitter
imagine if he bought
uh twitter he bought nine point two
percent just under three billion it goes
up twenty five percent he says he walks
away half a billion dollars thank you
thanks
he would lose like that's a reputation
killer i don't think he would do that
i know it's elon musk
snl which in my mind discredits
essentially everything that he said
about crypto but
i don't think so
because then he went he bought a billion
and a half dollars or whatever a bitcoin
and put on tesla's balance sheet and
then randomly was like oh yeah i own a
bunch of bitcoin too and also spacex as
well sorry maybe the right way it's not
discrediting exactly what he says about
crypto it's more about uh i think it's
irresponsible of him to promote it to
other people right i mean that's fair if
you look at the price given people
because most of the people look most of
the people buying that stuff aren't
people that can manage to lose the money
they can't afford to lose the money that
they're going to end up losing on that
or have even lost already on that so not
necessarily that his opinion is
discredited he's obviously an extremely
intelligent person he he built payment
infrastructure at paypal right like he
understands a lot of this stuff i think
but ultimately i think it's
irresponsible what he did with that
that's fair i still think that he should
be the chief meme officer if i'm the
twitter ceo right now like literally i
hear the news this morning first phone
call making is the board then to my
lawyers and i'm saying hey can i make
this to the chief meme officer of
twitter so that i can completely defuse
the situation and tell him every single
time that you tweet you better sign the
tweet chief meme officer at twitter
it'd be a i mean literally it'd be the
most amazing marketing for twitter i was
gonna say probably the smartest thing
they've done in a decade
hey twitter call me i'll be the ceo
we'll make elon the chief meme officer
we got ideas for days the other thing i
would do too is i would immediately tell
him that uh
uh you want to
create a twitter office in austin texas
uh at the tesla factory and also you
want to put one at starbase
and just start to integrate it he's got
the two hottest companies in the world
like the guy's literally saying hey get
on my rocket ship i just bought 9.2
percent of your company yeah
rename your campus you know uh or i
would even take like the conference
rooms and start naming it and leak it to
the press and say like oh we named the
main conference room the you know the
musk mansion it is kind of funny because
it's not like he wants something like
absolutely absurd either he wants to
create memes and have free speech
you know what i mean like that's a
pretty easy thing to do usually like
elliott management try to take an
activist position at twitter and they
want to fire the ceo right yeah
we just get better memes on twitter and
like oh by the way can you guys stop
deleting tweets of people who you
disagree with yeah like those are just
two asks by the way both of which will
make the platform better
i've been feeling the ceos lawyer call
also determined he was like hey can this
guy tweet anything that can get us in
trouble as owners of the platform right
and they were probably worried about
that he probably just wants to make sure
he's not going to get deleted yeah
he's got what 80 million i know at some
point i'ma say something that could be
controversial like you know put me right
on the line he's still got his horns
locked with the sec right yeah aren't
they going back and forth he he's he's
funding secured he sent he sent a wild
message back to them uh in the latest uh
i saw some article let's see here hold
on what did he say in the uh in the
latest one
he uh oh yeah
elon musk's lawyer quotes eminem lyrics
in the latest scc legal filing
imagine being his lawyer imagine his
lawyer you're like trying to have a
serious conversation he's like no just
send him the lyrics from that eminem
song
what is that song that eminem used to
sing
what did he say
yeah
part of the filing said the sec will let
me be or let me be me so let me see they
tried to shut me down
all the time
imagine getting that and being like
reading through the filing and being
like that's a weird like what is this
like wording and this is like dude
it probably took them a little while to
figure it out definitely yeah
the sec won't let me be or let me be me
so let me see they try to shove me down
that's all time
unbelievable
absolutely unreal hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time